we're helping people who are struggling
through their dating experiences
and rejoining me as friend of the show
and relationship expert
demona hoffman hi demona
okay now we just met katie um who
is like you know no nonsense about the
dates if she's not into it
demona said do a screening and that way
you don't even have to waste time on the
actual physical date
susan met a guy actually online
in a virtual date and he showed up naked
but now we want to hear from a gentleman
okay christian is here and he's been
having a hard time letting go christian
what is going on in your dating life
talk to us
thanks for having me um i went on a few
dates with someone and then they said
that they just weren't
that into it what's your best advice on
getting a resume that you've only been
on a few dates with
is it okay if i ask them to tell me tell
me what went wrong between us
oh christian christian you're a catch
you don't need to
chase that kind of closure right
like sometimes something goes wrong and
we think it must have been something
that
i did or there must be something that
is is causing this to happen but
sometimes it's just
not a match and trying to get that
information you expend
a lot of emotional energy right
so i like to think that everyone comes
into your life
for a reason but not everybody is there
for
a romantic connection and so i take that
marie condo philosophy
of thank and release if you've ever like
cleaned out your closets with that
it's the same thing everyone comes in
for a reason you thank them for the time
that you spent together and then you
release them back into the wild
if you notice this is a pattern and all
of your relationships always end the
same way at the same time
then we can talk about what you might be
doing and how we might address your
strategy but otherwise i want you to
just go forward confidently
and know that that person wasn't a fit
but if you keep at it you will find
somebody
that is the right match for you also i
have to say anyone
demon is right if it's a constant
pattern then we've got to do
some looking um but thank
people for not wasting your time staying
in longer
is longer drag out waste of time in life
longer to get over
they're saving you time susan demona is
right
don't let one naked man
ruin it for everyone and
associate dating apps because they are
you know what's happening now
with that one experience because you are
amazing and deserve whatever it is
you're looking for
and katie i like your no-nonsense ways
you're going to save yourself some time
and thanks to demona
now you found out a way to do that i
want to thank everybody
for being on the show i love love
relationships dating i'm
i love dissecting it it's so fun thank
you so much